We're here with the contributing editor
of one of my favorite magazines on planet earth,
House Beautiful, and founder of Kingston Design Connection,
Interior Designer, Maryline Damour.
(audience cheering and applauding)
All right, you've just helped a viewer on their dining room.
Yes, I did.
To great success, in my opinion.
Oh, thank you.
And we have an audience member
who has a little design dilemma, in a special Drew & A.
Where is Tamara Lynch?
Right here.
Hello!
(audience applauding)
Hi Drew.
My flower sees your flower.
I am a passionate flower lover,
so I am so happy to be here with you.
What is your design question, so everybody knows?
So, I have this sofa. I've had her for over 12 years.
And if you sit in my couch, you sink into it.
What's significant about this couch,
you know, people will be like,
oh, just throw it away, and get a new one.
It's not that easy, you know?
I lost my job to the pandemic,
I worked as a restaurant worker, and then was basically told
to sit down on March 16th, 2020.
And when my job came back,
we only took 25% of the workforce.
So it was a different life for me.
I spent a lotta time depressed on this couch.
But I've always been a resilient person,
and I just feel like putting one foot in front of the other
is just, even when you can't see where you're going,
you just do it.
And while I was on that couch,
(audience applauding)
I did something watching your show,
which was just go online and say,
put my name like just a random place.
And to be given a gift, like just for your phone to ring,
and say, "Hi, I have a random act of kindness for you,"
has been, just profound.
Profound. It has been profound.
(audience applauding)
That's all I can say.
I love your attitude of putting one foot
in front of the other.
Your sentimentality towards this couch
is completely understandable.
But telling your story, for me, is the key,
so thank you so much for sharing it-
Thank you, thank you so much. Thank you, really.
And it's not trivial to pivot to the couch.
I'm lucky that we are here with one of my design heroes.
I would love to know,
especially with that beautiful back story,
now what, Maryline?
Yeah, no. So I really, really wanted to honor your sofa.
I love that it's a part of your family.
And so one of the first things I did was to cover it
in one of the most hard wearing fabrics out there,
which is linen.
So linen will last you for many, many years to come,
and then there's some colorful pillows on top.
And the other thing is, you didn't previously have a carpet,
and I know in smaller spaces
people tend to think of adding less,
but really defining a space, it's kinda counterintuitive,
but it actually helps to give you the look and feel
of a bigger space.
And it defines it as a real living room.
So bringing that carpet in is really important.
The other thing that you didn't have was a coffee table,
so the coffee table's important,
because it just makes the space more functional.
And you can actually find these sometimes with shelves,
so it gives you a little bit more storage.
So I brought that in as well.
And overall, the idea is to really honor your living room,
to make it a place that you can continue to add to
over the years.
So you can imagine a brightly covered throw,
more flowers, some artwork.
But you know, the sofa will really become kinda the anchor
of your space.
Thank you, that's beautiful.
(audience applauding)
That's beautiful.
That's gorgeous.
What do you think, Tamara?
(Tamara chuckles)
Do you like it?
That's really beautiful.
I just love the coolness of it. That is beautiful.
Thank you.
I love it.
And you're absolutely right, the more you add
into a small space, the bigger it seems.
It's counterintuitive indeed.
Yeah, it's weird.
But it's true. Pack it.
I love it. I hope you do too.
(audience applauding)
Yeah, I do. I think it's so sophisticated.
All right. Well, thank God.
Because it's all going home with you.
Every single thing in this room,
we are putting in your living room.
The coffee table, the couch, the pillows,
the throws, everything.
And we have $2,000 for you to do whatever you want with,
and then I'm gonna match it, so that's four.
Oh my gosh.
(audience applauding)
And let's just round it up to five.
Where it's just five for you to do with it as you see fit,
to make your home life a little bit brighter.
And I thank you so much. Really and truly.
You're a blessing.
(audience applauding)
You're just an angel.
And Maryline, thank you, as always, so much.
Oh, thank you.
You're just so amazing.
(Maryline chuckles)
It looks so sophisticated.
Thank you.
(bright upbeat theme music)